welcome ladies and gentlemen back to
code tech tutorials
today we're going to be taking a look at
the no code movement
it's just going to be an information
video i'm just going to
basically look at what this is and then
at the end i'll make some comments about
it so a quick
google search of the no code movement
reveals
that it's on the rise from the sitepoint
article
there's articles about which tools to
use
and what it means for software
developers
and there's a free website builder
builder from webflow
not sponsored this video is brought to
you by my patrons
if you want to help support future
videos consider
signing up on the old patronage and uh
being one of those guys so
shout out to you guys all right let's
let's dig in no code no
code i just want to be so you're
probably asking
what is this exactly what do you mean no
code well i
will explain
now according to this site article
it's on the rise and let's just talk
about
what this is i don't know if they say it
blatantly here so i'll just say it
it's basically the idea of creating
software
without touching a line of code so how
do you do this
you uh ride on the backs
of all those who have coded before you
so your no code is actually a bunch of
people
a bunch of other people's else's code i
know they said that weird but
the point is there is tons of code
behind the note code
which it kind of boggles my mind why
it's called no code but i get it
from the person developing the the end
app
or the end website you don't touch a
line of code because you're using
everybody else's tools and everybody
else's code
that's it the whole idea is you don't
need to code you can make anything
without coding
so let's just talk about the benefits
real quick i'm just going to read this
article
and looks like they uh have a little
personal example
when we were in the thick of product
development for cloud peeps
don't know what that is i remember how
frustrating it was for our developers
and me
when i needed to make any any updates to
our
market pages or funnels well i can
happily edit html
congrats united html having a custom
built platform meant deploying
changes was limited to the depths
priority prioritizing feature
developments alongside bug fixes tweaks
was a challenge progress was slow we
tried numerous a b testing tools
moving to popular cms but the user
experience started to suffer
okay the tools like web while tools like
webflow existed
i always saw that link this isn't that
though this is sitepoint
they were touted as mainstream solution
solutions so we lacked
awareness to implement them since then
the rise of no code tools has
changed the game forever not only for
tasks like marketing pages but also for
full stack
apps which people can now build end to
end in 2014.
oh in 2014 if you wanted to build a
marketplace you had to develop it from
scratch after that
offers offerings like share tribe come
along to make
uh with standard marketplace software in
a box an ongoing price tag you can build
whatever marketplace setup you want
using no code tools so there you have it
it's basically
using a bunch of tools to build
well there looks like they're mainly
talking about websites here
i don't know if you can do this for
anything sure there are tons of assets
for a thing like
things like the unreal and unity engine
so you might be able to get away with it
it just depends what you're doing i just
i can't see this being relevant
for game development well beyond a
certain extent
but it looks like you can set up your
full website
with no code i guess this is wysiwyg
stuff
uh what you see is what you get you know
you drag and drop things you set it up
how you want you add in
things let's take a look at this next
one
the rise of the no code movement yes
we'll
we'll take your cookies send them to me
give me your cookies all right
no code might ring a bell or be
completely
new but one thing is for sure this year
you will hear a lot about it and here's
why
all right it's worth the no code
movement is worth a bunch okay that
seems weird to me
surprising not so much the value of no
code is clear as day allows people to
have big ideas but no coding skills to
start creating
immediately all right well this is
dangerous
because well just go look at my software
core video
that's that's why this is dangerous
we're gonna have a bunch of janky stuff
where people don't actually know
how the tools they've integrated are
working
well i don't know that's that's me just
kind of looking at the cons
yeah so you don't have to code you just
just write on the backs of all the
coders that came before you
all right well why is it so popular
basically because people don't want to
learn how to code
because it's too hard probably removes
the challenges of coding and opens up a
world of possibilities
i don't i don't know there's something i
don't have anything against this
but there's something like inherently
insulting
about this no code thing to programmers
all right let's look at something else
more interesting
now i think where this all kicked off
was from this kelsey
hightower slash no code github the best
way to write code
write nothing deploy nowhere start by
not writing any code
just an example application but you can
imagine it just you think what
i love this is still funny to me i don't
know if this is a joke
mocking the note code movement or if
this is a literal
ad for it but it has
so many almost 50k stars and there's
literally nothing in here except
this meme about no code i can't tell if
this
i really can't tell if this is like uh
he was just feeling like oh
let me just make fun of this no code
thing and put this up
or if this was legit like oh this is
actually better here we go
there's a docker file there's nothing in
it
i love it i love it all right well let's
see if we can find anything
any other useful information for you in
this video
all right well i did a search for why
use no code
and i got a few things
i'm not sure which is going to be the
best here
so we're just going to take a peek
and uh yeah here we go you can see the
website i'm on so
no need for me to over advertise that so
that's why no code development is
getting so much attention why is that
well they talk about what it is okay so
i guess the major problem is
custom making your code takes a long
time to develop
and it's hard for other developers to
get on get in on and all that
so iteration time can be pretty huge
enter the no code
development you've probably heard of
this term being thrown around sounds
promising doesn't really make that much
a difference
can't really make life smoother for you
and your department staff
let's just read these first paragraphs
of these what is the no code development
a platform that uses visual development
environment to allow
layman users to create apps okay so like
wysiwyg
editors gotcha through methods such as
drag
drop adding application components to
complete an application with no code
users don't need prior coding knowledge
to create apps
okay well i can see yeah pussywig
editors have always had their place
but the problem is they turn into like
janky pieces of mess because things
don't
actually work as you always intend or
they don't have the proper
i don't know like you resize your page
and things are stuck on the top left or
something there's always there's always
weird stuff going on
when you don't get to control the code
behind it because it's always doing
something you don't want
but i guess you know the tools are
improving maybe it's not as bad as it i
remember
benefits of no code application
development platforms you know the
obvious benefit of taking some weight
off your chest by letting
other teams create applications without
knowing how to code or is
one trick pony better agility reduced
cost more productivity easily changeable
okay and no code development does work
in the real world there's been a growing
requirement for developers since the
start of information age
the backbone of websites and
applications yeah
we sure are code is running the world it
continues
okay do companies use it more and more
companies are finding
value in the no code app development
platform
and putting their eggs in this basket
all right so
let's let's just take a look at this why
you should go no code without a reliable
way to allow your business users to
develop their own applications your
problems are going to be compounded
you're going to find more and more cases
of shadow i.t popping up
all over the organization companies
underestimate
the reach of shadow it i don't know what
shadow i.t means
on average cios are way off the mark by
a factor of 15 to 22 what does that mean
off the mark by a factor of 15 to 22
that sounds massive is that as massive
as i think it is all right cisco thought
that it only had to be around 51 cloud
services operating in the organization
but there is an actual check file the
number was 720
you have to mitigate this this doesn't
really say
i feel like this is not a very good
explanation of why you should go no code
but
all right maybe i'm missing something
if you come this far you're looking for
a way to clear your department's
never-ending queue
requests and complaints
all right overall you know i just want
to say
i think my problem with this is well
things have already mentioned
sure it has its benefits of anyone could
go and edit stuff but
i feel like it's just going to get
more convoluted and confusing
the more and more people that mess with
it that don't really understand it
the worse your software is going to get
and i feel like that
is a big part of this people are just
going to be like oh just download this
node thing drop it in of course that was
just
i don't know if node's a good example
here i feel like node.js using libraries
is sort of similar but you still do need
to code
so yeah there's a lot more information
out here about this
let me know your guys's thoughts down
below what do you think of this no code
movement
is it something that just takes
advantage of developers or is it
destined to be a mess or is it way
better i don't know
i'm kind of on the fence here i can't
really tell it seems like there's some
things that are definitely better about
it
like if you could iterate fast that's
nice
but then what if something goes wrong
that you don't know how to
drop in some no code thing to fix
what what then are you just completely
stuck
that's that's where i i kind of lose it
because i
you know i would rather do the back and
stuff custom
personally it's usually not that hard
especially with libraries
all right i'll catch you guys in the
video next video
matt from code tekken tutorials over and
out
[Music]
once again a massive shout out to my
patrons it does
really really mean a lot to me and
you can get on this list for next month
if you want to go ahead and sign up
it does make a really huge difference
for me producing these videos lately
as uh things rough at home but i'm not
going to talk about that much on this
channel just
you know you know things happen and it
isn't always easy to produce
videos consistently you know infinitely
i'd love to make videos every day
but you know things come up day to day
and sometimes it is
me thinking about these patrons that are
supporting me
that give me the push to say hey this is
something you do now
we're supporting you get out there and
do it so
thank these four for the tutorials that
come out this month
because they're pretty much carrying it
sign up help us all out and uh yeah i'd
appreciate it
out for real this time
[Music]
you